hello on a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany and my
guest today is a man who's widely viewed
as one of the best young writers in
Germany and areas in person David Wagner
hello I gave it can be very very much
for joining us here today on talking
Germany now David Varma has won a number
of prizes for his essays articles
columns poetry and novels including this
year the prestigious Leipzig book fair
price for his most successful book yet
which is called quite simply a life
David welcome once again you will have
noticed that I said there that you are
often viewed by the critics here in
Germany as one of the best young writers
in Germany one of the best of the young
generation my young what do you make of
that oh well it doesn't disturb me in my
work so I it's very interesting to read
what the critics write about yourself
you have to sort of focus on your work
or what you do on your writing and it is
it tells you it helps you to get support
but still you're alone at your desk with
writing so and the product of you being
alone at your desk is your latest book
called leben in Germany yeah I just
translated it as life was I right to do
so because Laban can translate as life
and as living as living yeah and that's
the am biggity with the title I play
with and it's it's also the plural its
life's as well so and it tells the story
of a man who has to be in hospital for
over a year and he gets to know stories
of other people's lives as well so and
it's his own life story in this book and
it's about living so you have all this
combined I wouldn't know how translated
I like it very very much indeed i have
to tell you the scituate that the
circumstance under which and I came to
read it first of all I was going to read
it because I knew you were coming on the
show so we're cycling around Berlin one
day with my daughter
and I went into one of my favorite book
shops in the Shona beg district and
bought the book we came out we sat in a
cafe and I started reading the first two
paragraphs of your book and I thought
wow I thought this is engrossing this is
very good this is a guy who can write
really well and is writing about
something very important and I told my
daughter this yeah and she said we'll go
and read me the first two paragraphs
yeah so I did and she said wow how old
is your daughter there's the question
she's 17 yeah and I told her today yeah
that I was going to ask you she said to
me after I'd read it to her she was just
as you know she was taken in by it she
said I want to read that after you and i
said i will ask David Wagner himself
whether he thinks that's a good idea for
a 17 year old girl to be reading the
book I think it will absolutely i've
heard of other 17 or even younger girls
and boys who've read it and oh well uh i
read a lot of books before I should have
read them maybe I remember but no it's a
I think you you read you get what what
you can get and that's that's good okay
one more question before I have a look
at a portrait of you um you're saying
you're sitting here and you're telling
me that this book which is a very very
emotional book is a book about a man
you're acting as though it's a guy
across there or a guy yeah but yeah is
it you it's part of me it's a sort of
technique for me to talk about this saw
which is a very intimate story it's a
it's known that I went through the story
I I got a liver transplant
transplantation I wouldn't be sitting
here I wouldn't be talking to you if I
hadn't had this transplantation and I
feed some how safe they are by this
operation and this made a story and
that's a story I wanted to tell their
and but it's not so easy to to tell and
to this very intimate story so I i
transformed it into another and
I had to I had to add a little fiction
okay
it's quite interesting looking at that
reporter that there's a sort of desert
you before and are you after I think
it's fair to say yeah I was wondering
who was this young man I don't recognize
it was a the UN shuttle of it the you
after is to get exactly a stroking a
beer there you're the guy with the beard
Miriam um let's talk about you your your
very early days you grew up in a family
it was not a family of writers no my
parents are both more or less work in
economics or in yeah in my father worked
in sort of in surroundings in in born
near the government in nicely banks and
so on and but there were always books
around and there was always reading and
it's uh uh yeah I my brother's an
investment banker I started I started to
study economics started to study ha but
I stopped very very fast so yeah when
did you you're a storyteller yeah am I
hear a story yeah yeah what was the
first story you ever told what was the
first story you ever wrote down we were
youngster will you have a wee little guy
where you were at school or a college um
it's very bizarre because I i stumbled
upon an old sort of story i sort of
dictated to my mother when I was like
four or five years old so you dictated
it she wrote it there because I couldn't
write yes that was a very bizarre story
about his deep-sea diver in the rhine
and some some bizarre things and and
about a horse doesn't Martines fear
doesn't Martin's Horace riding it's a
st. Matthew the guy who kept looking
yoku curtis and gave it to the poor and
so a bizarre fantasies sort of story but
after that there was a long break in
storytelling and I got only back to when
I was like 16 17
I started to write down things and I
have to admit I I must have written very
bad poetry these days as a young guy you
lived in you left in Rome or a younger
guy you lookin bro nah barcelona mexico
city where else paris i studied in Paris
for nearly two years and so in Paris you
get to know a lot of people from all
over the world and so I got a girlfriend
in mexico and i went to mexico and
stayed there and i had this very dear
friend from Rome and so we changed
apartments and I did the same thing with
Barcelona so somehow this this was a
sort of student exchange program this
Paris thing started like this and so I
somehow had the opportunities to go to
all these places and there was no master
plan in this cosmopolitan existence no
it's one let's go to the other and I I
found out that I I was very a laser in
being abroad yeah yeah it was very
comfortable yeah I was very comfortable
to be and somehow I I understood this
this Germany thing from abroad better
and I could so when I when I was in
Mexico what is the Germany so yeah I I
learned that I was German when I wasn't
in France and when I was in Paris and I
felt before the first time what was the
German have seen you yeah that the
peculiar thing is that that growing up I
never wanted to be German this is like
this that's your generation yeah this is
a generation thing and when the the
reunification came I was I was not in
favor of beautification I thought what a
bizarre but we don't need this and why
do we need the GDR so this this or this
Germany talking this was very strange to
me and somehow being abroad was somehow
I was I felt I there is something German
room
that didn't make me a patriotic guy here
and so but so I 5 i've developed some
comfortable miss with ya okay again a
pretty typical process for your
generation yeah let me ask you this
because the viewers must be thinking
what he's written this book about this
the the liver transplant this whole
process that you said saved your life
yeah where did that whole process began
we heard in the report you were 12 years
old when that first came into play as it
were well um you're asking me about the
the illness so yeah it was um I was like
12 years old then it was only detected
and then they found out that like half
of the liver was already destroyed so I
had to live with this reduced liver
capacity and I didn't but I don't want
to acknowledge this I I wanted to live
my life and so I I did all these things
going abroad and and doing whatever but
there was always this thing looming yeah
that I knew that someday I would need to
transplant or life would be over so and
somehow this led to some sort of focus
on work and on writing so I wrote the
first book the night blue trousers yeah
which is a sort of book about this West
Germany and this new Germany thing and
so I came to census with this story of
this rich saturated west germany i grew
up in the book is one of the fascinating
things that there's lots of things that
i really like about the book i like the
laconic style or like the humor but
there's also it really ask big questions
about about life and death yeah yeah i
mean you you're saying that it's you've
objective eyes that you've made it into
a book about a guy about a man yeah who
may or may not be you but there's one
section in the book I'm listening to you
talking about the young David Wagner and
there's one section in the book where
the 15 year old who may or may not be
used
says suicide seems like the only option
well yeah there's a melancholic part in
the book and you could explain this with
the physiological ology that the liver
doesn't weigh making a little twist
sometimes yeah despairing said yeah and
well I don't know this is um some part
of the story if that's part of the story
another part of the story is about the
consolation that life offers you what
are the consolations that life offers
you well lying in lying in hospital
having so much time having so much time
to think about everything and then all
this consolation your life has both of
you already comes back and you can think
about it and you have this memories and
it's some of that when when you're near
maybe are near the end of your life then
the your life story comes back and it's
it's blooming in a way and it's it's
it's there and it and that's that's the
thing that helps mm-hmm so it was
interesting in the book there is an
epilogue at the end of the book which is
very very short before that effectively
the last sentence of the book is a
father yeah you coming home it's your
daughter who offers great consolation to
you in the story throughout I think yeah
it does yeah been a motivator exactly
I suppose the first question is David do
you do you do have a donor card yourself
I have sure I have and I had one for a
long time yeah it's interesting I've had
one myself since 2011 there was I spent
an awful lot of time thinking about it
making it seamless seemed like a big
decision what's very interesting is
these days when I when I actually take
it out and show it to be more it's very
interesting to discover how many people
are as well shocked it's the right word
i'm not quite that a reaction you get
possibly not listen to know I always
have blank or carts on me so I can I
don't force them on people but if they
ask me I can give them one and you
should always bear in mind the chance to
that you yourself need an organ is much
much higher than the remote chance of
being an organ donor yourself so that's
things that's very interesting so what
you're saying is that you actually have
something maybe somewhere here in our
makeup sweet you probably have you you
have cards that you could give out the
folks here and say you know I fill it in
now and then you're and put it on the
wallet I wouldn't say fill it in now I
would say think about it here in it so
and I think it's it's only fair that
every grown-up person one day thinks
about it and naturally goes there and
makes a decision yeah yeah whatever the
decision may be but it's a thing I think
a grown-up person can do ok so it's
become a slightly problematic process in
Germany in the last couple of years or
so because of what the German media when
they get excited like to call the
transplant scandal yeah maybe scandal
isn't the right word i'm not sure can
you just explain what that's all about
well organs are the very scare a scarce
and so the problem is that some some
doctors manipulated the waiting lists
they they made patients more ill than
they were and so helped help them to get
an organ this was only two to push their
careers because doctors and
and the clinics are rated when they are
when they would do a lot of transplants
so the problem behind that is a
political problem that we don't have in
law how to distribute these organs and
so this is the scandal okie dokie was it
partly for that reason that there was
there was a sort of a mood of skepticism
around the donor process because of that
so-called scandal was that part of the
reason may be a small part why you
actually wrote it's it's obviously it's
some thumb some like somehow this this
organ transplantation organ donor thing
is a lot of people a sort of mystery
still and they it's not very people
don't like to to think about it and it's
but still it's um you you you just it's
it's not a it's not a big thing to have
this card and you always have to have to
think that's the chance that you become
a donor is so remotely remotely and on
the other hand there are all these
people who who die if they don't get an
organ so I am I am lucky i'm sitting
only here because some somebody gave his
organ and so i'm very grateful for that
tell us a little bit about what it is
like to be in the sort of the waiting
loop to be on the waiting list that's a
pretty tortured place to be uh it's it's
a bizarre situation that's it's very you
don't actually you don't think about it
every day then it's um and and actually
when the car came that there there was
an organ i was i was very surprised i
didn't think of it i always thought I
it's it's it would be in years maybe or
no what's it like and this is something
you write about in the book just share
that a little bit with our viewers what
is it like to carry within you the organ
part of somebody else's body somebody
else's vital organ as we say oh yeah
this is something you you have to think
about and you have to yeah there is
something of someone else in your body
and this is like the person which is
closest to you and so in the book the
guy in the book the man he somehow he
his solution is to he he has the
imagination of a of a young woman who
gave this organ and which is somehow his
beloved his it's a sort of romantic
concept of love yeah and you have to
somehow yeah find a personal arrangement
with this story because it is it is
something to wonder about endlessly yeah
one of the things I know you found quite
difficult was that you you're a letter
writer yeah you're somebody who likes to
write letters which i think is a
wonderful thing yet and you wanted to
write a letter saying thank you to the
person who had donated the organ and
that was fair balton that wasn't that
wasn't allowed yeah yeah well there is
the possibility to write to the
relatives of the donor but you have to
do it in a strictly anonymous way and so
you're not allowed to tell who you are
your name or what you do away even the
city where you live so and this this
would be like a letter without any
qualities like like the writer without
qualities so am i wasn't able to do that
I was only able to write this book which
is now it bears my name on it so i can
send it but in a way it's it's a say to
say thank you to all of these donors
yeah who made a huge big donor i made a
big difference in your life that's for
sure yeah
where to start let's go back you
mentioned your first novel yeah my
midnight blue trousers y and I've got a
quote here one second there we go you
say about the book it's a book about
Berlin in the early 90s oh you're an
expert on this period we just been
looking at and then you describe that
period old houses ruins no telephones in
the houses no bathrooms yeah no real
heating yeah yeah what was I mean that
doesn't sound good too many people what
was the thrill yeah the thrill was it
was so different than West Germany it
was somehow like like the post-war had
been preserved and and you had these
flats with you had open eating and there
with Cole and but they were very very
cheap they cost nearly nothing so and
it's actually had a huge playground and
could do all the things you dreamt about
and what have you been dreaming about
doing that you then did in this
playground well I uh I have to admit I I
went to university know the good boy
yeah well no yeah there were these
informal clubs in this Boris which we
are illegal in a way or if not been sort
of hidden in basements and in ruins
literally in ruins and so this was a
very exciting time and you know it's 20
years ago now more or less or even more
and it's the sort of nostalgia has set
in and now it's it's some some but
looking back and no now maybe maybe I I
missed that and I missed that and
because the peculiar thing is that when
I tell people are you here you were a
year in the 90s they say on an essay
yeah but living then I was always
thinking oh I missed the 80s and I
missed shona back and David Bowie and I
missed that so and i missed the war
berlin and so it's always it's
looking back you are the hero of your
time yeah how has Berlin changed since
then and now I know that that's
something you're writing about yeah well
that's been writing about yeah I still
do and well the obvious thing a lot a
lot of things have been built and Berlin
used to be more empty much more empty
yes wonderful German word the word bow
Luka bowler cakes I'm power Lucas a bow
Luca means that there are two buildings
and in between there's nothing so cause
because nothing has been built or had
been built or the special case of Berlin
some bomb fell down and destroyed the
building and so and we had a lot of
these it's amazing I mean you can still
now in Berlin you can walk along streets
in Berlin and you can see a bow looker
and you look at it you know that
building got blasted away in the second
world war and they are in the in the end
come from Berlin or yeah and it's um so
the city has been filled up and even I
have fear the feeling that more people
are in the streets yeah so it used to be
the saying in the early 90 so this is
the city but but where are where other
people there are there no people living
here and in some areas this has changed
don't care it's interesting is your
views on bill in a quite important
because you're the critics tend to talk
about you because of your I think you're
on your third book now about Berlin yeah
people call you they use a French word
which the Germans love ya which is
slander and there's no no like sort of
this from the from the French night the
late 19th century yeah with French
intellectuals sloping about town
thinking big thoughts about City yeah
and people say well David Wagner is a
fun or you say ahaha no I'm not yeah
well I don't especially like this this
word it's a sort of snobby thing I I'm a
Roma yeah I'm i roam the city I my true
i roam yeah
around a walk or I ramble I don't know
yeah you know you said I wrote down a
word that used you say in German I have
diesel that you're addicted to walking
yeah that's in a way walking clears my
mind and in berlin berlin never Boris
you when you when you walk through
Berlin so stories you tell about Berlin
where do you get them from because
they're quite sort of street-level story
do you get them from talking to people
or do you get them from old publications
are both or mostly just from looking at
at buildings and streets and bowling and
because the city itself itself tells the
story and it's that's very easy in
building to see because you you see all
the historic cuts you see the Berlin of
the Kaiser time of a flaming will me
near the light light late 19th century
and you see Nancy Berlin and you see the
GDR Berlin and you you see all this and
that is like an open book and you know
it's very layered layer on top of layer
yeah yeah what's gonna happen next in
Berlin oh I'm here to stay so tell me
what's coming my way well Berlin is one
of the top destinations in these days I
sometimes fear maybe this can this can
change easily because i have seen berlin
on the top and i've seen it on the
downturn and I oh maybe the next nadir
is looming I don't know about that that
quote that we had at the end of that
report that the Berlin mayor once said
Berlin is poor but sexy is that true is
that good you go with it it's the
sexiness I'm not sure about but the
corners yeah that's right
mr. Wagner until now I thought you were
a very modest spirit but you've just
been telling me that under now has
produced another very famous right God's
Philippines who's the other famous
writer from I mean you're one of them
yeah I'm sorry no this this Charles
Bukowski yeah yeah he was born in and
Anna in 1916 oh not 20 something like
this yeah right after the first world
war and but he went to the US us in many
was two years old okay so it's not so I
I haven't met him there Charles Bukowski
as the case the Americans like to say um
what do you make how many boat trips
have you been on some there used to be a
ferry in and Anna so am I could cross
the Ryan to the other side and what did
you do at the other side oh how to drink
and contain a very thick the landscape I
mean the report has got very different
music from the hard techno of the Berlin
report and it's a little bit sort of
it's sort of that cozy kind of music but
it it is Germany and it's very beautiful
very beautiful it is it's some hard well
when I be there when I went to go there
in these days it it still warms my heart
anyway and it I have this sort of
romantic Rhine soul yeah it's a the
Rhine as a landscape it was ya found
detected by by by British by British
tourists in the 19th century and they
had this touristic click on the Rhine
well II yeah so they saw it is the
remote they invented it they invented it
yeah yeah so um and III have a I have an
old English map of the Rhine in my and
my and near my desk though and I time to
time so watch on it and the speciality
about this map it's the south is is on
top not the north so it's
the view going down they were going to
the river yeah so going from the from
the Upper Rhine brine lower yeah yeah so
it's a difficult concept for children to
crash yeah tell me a little bit more
about and enough then what makes it I
mean your heart beats for the place
still obviously hmm well no well I I've
not been there very often in the last 20
years but but still it's it's somehow
growing up there I I somehow i sucked in
the concept of a romantic small city and
it has ruins it has head says
fortifications it hasn't a very an old
tower and it is an emblematic romantic
Roman founded city so this helps me a
lot comparing this to this very very
different Berlin which very different
poles of Germany different port and yeah
yeah but still it's it's inside me this
is a very german thing the small city
yeah wonderful yeah the romantic david
berg now yeah the successful David
Wagner you've you've won the light to
book prize you've been praised very much
for your latest book does that change
your life has that put you under
pressure no no no I I I sit alone on my
desk working every day or hopefully
every day but I can only go on so don't
go well yeah okeydoke that's a lot with
the thought provoking David Wagner
there's more talking German including my
blog on our and our archived on our
website if you've enjoyed the show today
come back next week bye bye until then
just
now I'll tell you the quiz
you